this next story is it's unbelievable and
yet it's predictable because it's
florida
florida
has suspended a public health official a
doctor for encouraging his own staff to
get vaccinated uh it's it's insane and
it's dystopian npr reports florida
department of health confirms dr raul
pino put on leave
for encouraging orange county department
of health employees to get vaccinated
didn't require anybody to get vaccinated
encouraged people to get vaccinated and
he has been suspended the florida
department of health medical director
that oversees areas of orange county
including orlando has been put on leave
for encouraging encouraging his own
staff to get vaccinated
orange county medical director dr raul
pino wrote an email to staff on january
4th
encouraging them to get vaccinated and
boosted for covid in it he wrote quote
i'm having a hard time understanding how
we can be in public health and not
practice it makes perfect sense sensible
down to earth statement
after sending the email he was placed on
administrative leave in an email to wmfe
florida department of health confirmed
he was on leave because quote the
decision to get vaccinated is a personal
choice that should be free from coercion
and mandates from employers
now encouraging is not demanding
it is not coercion it is not a mandate
it is not offering a consequence if you
fail to do it it's just hey you know
like we're in public health and there's
these vaccines and they're very good at
keeping people alive when they get
covered and we we should really get them
it's kind of weird that we work in
public health and we whoa we people need
to be free from mandates also dystopian
florida department of health says it's
even conducting an inquiry into whether
any laws were broken by sending the
email republican governor ron desantis
has banned vaccine mandates in the
workplace
and the state has seen a surge in
omicron cases
what
what and also remember that before it
became politically inconvenient to ron
desantis ron desantis was encouraging
vaccination more recently desantis was
asked if he's boosted and he didn't even
want to answer the question
and the encouragement of vaccination has
stopped but when it was a different
political situation when it was
trump made the vaccines and let's go get
them ron desantis had a very different
outlook and at the end of the day ron
desantis is determined to spread covet
as far and wide as possible into the
nooks and crannies of the state of
florida uh and
what's the if saying hey guys um since
we practice public health we should
actually practice it and get vaccinated
no mandate no coercion no threat of
firing but we should probably do it
that now is not allowed
uh de facto because he was placed on
administrative leave what's going to be
next you go to the pharmacy hey by the
way uh you're picking up your pills
did you know that we have vaccines
available and they're free to you did
you want to get one have you been
vaccinated whoa that's coercion
pharmacists shouldn't even be allowed to
do that that's the next step when you
say this
action by dr raul pino
deserves a suspension which of course it
doesn't and we'll see whether he is
ultimately fired
whether he comes back with some kind of
reprimand whether he quits or whatever
the case may be